what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so you guys didn't actually think I
was gonna leave you on the whole event
of like Sabretooth getting out of an
tiem you think I was gonna genuinely
just leave you on that I mean surely not
truly you have more faith in me than
that now here's the cool thing about
that the other half that story sucks
it's basically just saber-toothed
Wolverine and Kitty Pryde teaming up to
defeat Hydra and then like Vipers like
yeah so I'm officially in charge of
magic or this criminal City and like
that's it like nothing of any real note
happens and the rest of that story it's
the first part that matters for our
discussion here now what I want to do
here is I want a sidetrack I want to
backtrack all the way to Wolverine vol 1
issue number 93 all the way to 100 this
was like the first part of this
adamantium saga so to speak or I guess
really the first part was fatal
attractions when he lost his adamantium
in the first place I guess this would be
the second part so the whole idea of of
why this matters you know Wolverine 93
to 100 is that this brings into the into
fray a character by the name of Genesis
also known as Tyler Dayspring now one of
the things that I saw people commenting
on is they were like well I thought
Genesis was the one that gave Wolverine
is out of mantium back no he tried me
failed so here's the way this whole
thing works Genesis Tyler Dayspring is
the son of cable he's a son of cable
from you know the future more or less
the idea is that cable exists in two
forms
there is cable nathan summers and then
there's strife strife is basically
everything cable could be strife is a
monster do that guy is so beast that
dude I I loved strife as a character
like he's do he's evil he's vindictive
but he's crazy powerful but because of
the fact that strife was raised by the
villain apocalypse he's like the angsty
teenager that never let go of his angst
he's just angry all the time but he also
views cable as his mortal enemy and any
opportunity that strife can take to
either kill or defeat cable is an
opportunity that he will take in this
instance strife had actually kidnapped
the son of cable Tyler Dayspring then
brainwashed him turned him to his side
and then Tyler Dayspring ended up
becoming a bad guy now the other half of
this is that cable was forced to shoot
Tyler due to the fact that you know
Tyler had basically threatened the life
of one of cables teammates it was
basically someone close to cable Tyler
was gonna kill him cable had to shoot
him and that basically turned Tyler into
an enemy of cables for almost eternity
so because of that
Tyler would go back in time and try to
find ways to defeat his dad now the
difference is Marvel never really wrote
Tyler like strife right like strife was
like if I can kill him I'm gonna kill
him
but with Tyler it was really more of
like potshots and he would just kind of
crop up from time to time but the idea
was that he effectively wanted to use
Wolverine for his purposes of trying to
take out cable the problem with this was
that Wolverine didn't have any
adamantium and so in Wolverine issues 93
through 100 what ended up happening is
it was this long drawn-out thing where
it was basically a Tyler Dayspring
sending his forces after Wolverine and
then grabbing Wolverine and bringing him
back and trying to bond adamantium to
his skeleton the problem with this is
that it failed in disastrous
consequences but the reason why this is
like the second phase of the adamantium
saga is because the failure of Genesis
to try to bond adamantium to a wolf rain
basically just sent him off into an
animalistic state and that's where feral
Wolverine comes from that's why he looks
more like an animal than an actual
person now this is a really cool line of
stories it didn't last way too long but
this is when Marvel started running into
the comic bust right like it was the
idea of comics sales are just plummeting
we basically have to find a way to get
people to buy them again and so this
story what basically came to a
screeching halt and what Marvel ended up
doing was setting things back to rights
almost immediately
now the other half of this is that this
leads directly into a story called the
twelve the twelve was a story that was
written in 2000 by Chris Claremont I
think it was it was really a crossover
so it was like Chris Claremont and it
was Allen Davis and it was Terry
Cavanagh and Eric Larson and all these
different guys who were writing it but
the idea was that Marvel grabbed the
villain apocalypse and said okay
apocalypse is trying to grab godly power
he's trying to become God and the way in
which he can do this is to grab a
handful of mutant mutants known as the
twelve now this came out of a character
that was named destiny I believe leave
her name was destiny it was destinies
Diaries and it was the idea that destiny
could see the future and people would
grab her Diaries or at least it was it
was an attempt to seek out her diaries
to one acquire the future and to because
her diaries had key information about
characters who were of significant or
who were you know particular import
different things like that the story of
the twelve was a apocalypse robbing the
shape-shifting race the scrolls and then
using them as it means to basically dupe
x-men different things like that but he
sought out magna
Polaris storms son fire Iceman Cyclops
and Phoenix I think and then cable
bishop I want to say Mikhail Rasputin
and Professor X but the idea was to
basically grab all those 12 mutants who
essentially represented like the
fundamental forces of the universe more
or less and then channel those energies
directly into himself and it was really
cool because what this would do is it
would basically give up hoc ellipse an
insane amount of power he would
basically make him a divine being for
those are the guys who remember x-men
the animated series there was an episode
called Beyond Good and Evil or I think
was a four part episode called Beyond
Good and Evil that's based on the 12 the
reason why this matters is because one
of the things that apocalypse did is he
basically had one of the scrolls
shape-shift themselves end up being wolf
rein in the background while the x-men
believed that Wolverine was actually on
their team
the real Wolverine had been taken by
apocalypse alongside Sabretooth and what
apocalypse did is he basically said my
horsemen death Warren Worthington has
essentially left like he's bailed out
and what I need to do is create a new
horsemen death and so kidnapping
Sabretooth and kidnapping a Wolverine
what this did is it allowed Marvel to
come back and say now we're going to
give Wolverine his adamantium back and
so what apocalypse did is he said
whichever one of you survives will
become my horseman death the caveat is
that a saber tooth survives he'll just
become the horseman if Wolverine
survives then Wolverine will not only
become the horseman death he will also
be given Sabretooth adamantium and
that's what this did this was covered in
I believe Wolverine issues 142 through
145 and maybe even all the way up to
issues 147 but it was basically this
idea that like Wolverine and Sabretooth
were forced to fight one another now the
funny thing about this is that this is
interspersed basically with a fight with
The Incredible Hulk and it's kind of
cool because at the time we didn't even
know who this guy was would even know
who this horseman was it was just a
person who shows up with a samurai sword
out with this you know crazy looking
mask and then just immediately attacks
the Incredible Hulk now this changes
everything in terms of the Wolverine
versus Hulk battles and the reason for
this is because of the fact that while
this conflict between Sabretooth and
Wolverine is interspersed at the same
time that Wolverine is fighting the
Incredible Hulk what we end up having is
the battles between the two turned on
their head historically speaking and
really the debut of Wolverine came
the battle against the Incredible Hulk
the Incredible Hulk issues 180 and 181
but the battles between the two were
always pretty significant because it was
just regular Wolverine this gives us
Wolverine with modifications facing off
against the Incredible Hulk now kind of
jump me back and forth in between these
things
the battle between Wolverine and
Sabretooth is also pretty significant
and the reason for this is not
necessarily because of the fact that
Wolverine wants his adamantium back I
mean he does but he's also learned to
cope with bone claws the issue with this
is that Sabretooth this being classic
Sabretooth is more like a force of
nature I mean Sabretooth back during
like the 80s 90s and even going into the
2000s this guy was insane he was
absolutely nuts that's why I say there
are not very many treat level characters
that could faced off against Sabretooth
and succeed but for wolve reign
knowing that Sabretooth is as hardcore
as he is and knowing that Sabretooth is
as violent as he is it will not
necessarily be about Sabretooth being
the horsemen death and then just doing
whatever it is it apocalypse wants them
to do for Sabretooth it's the lust of
battle Sabretooth would enjoy going
around and killing people and that's
what makes him so dangerous as a
potential horseman with Warren
Worthington as the as the horsemen death
it was brainwashing it was an unwilling
thing with Sabretooth he would willfully
turn himself over to apocalypse and then
just go around and just kill everybody
that he can and so it would literally
just give Sabretooth free run of the
Marvel Universe jumping back into this
battle with Wolverine against against
the Hulk after becoming horsemen death
is a testing ground it's basically this
idea that apocalypse sends him forward
to see whether or not he's truly capable
of facing off against some of the
mightiest heroes that exist on earth now
notice this of all the characters that
Marvel could have picked they picked the
Incredible Hulk now half of this is
because of the fact that Wolverine
versus the Hulk is always something
people will read people will always read
a story called Wolverine versus hawk but
the other half of this is that the
Incredible Hulk is one of these
strongest if not the absolute strongest
character in the Marvel Universe so
because of this in the end he's not
necessarily able to defeat The
Incredible Hulk per se the Incredible
Hulk actually gets the better of him now
initially the Incredible Hulk defeats
him and then is just kind of like okay
I'm done and The Incredible Hulk blocks
off after beating him unconscious now of
course apocalypse teleports Wolverine
away and then basically says okay well
at least you
survived so I guess we can kind of go
with that now the other half of this is
remember apocalypse is not new to the
Incredible Hulk apocalypse has subdued
him in the past like he's literally
grabbed the Incredible Hulk and forced
him into being one of his horsemen the
problem is you can't do the same guide
twice and so because of that Marvel just
kind of left that out in this particular
bit of a story but with regards to
Wolverine getting his adamantium back
that's exactly what it seems like it's
literally just a series of hoses and you
know connections and so on they give the
adamantium back - and the problem with
this is that Marvel ignores a couple of
things that should not necessarily be
able to exist for example it's
established that when adamantium hardens
it cannot be liquefied again adamantium
is kept in a very particular State in
order to keep it liquid or once it cools
and it hardens didn't it's like that
forever
that's why Wolverines adamantium being
bonded to his skeleton was such a big
deal if all it took was extreme heat in
order to get the adamantium out of him
then somebody somewhere would have had
the genius idea to throw them into the
Sun and then just capture the adamantium
and put it in a vial and then take it
back to earth and bond it to somebody
else and so because of that Marvel kind
of ignores this they kind of ignore this
idea that adamantium cannot be liquefied
again now it's done for the sake of the
story and it works I mean it's you know
it serves its purpose
Wolverine gets his adamantium back but
this is what I was talking about when I
said that the whole epic of Wolverine
getting his adamantium return to him
kind of came to a screeching halt this
story came out at a time when Marvel was
almost bankrupt and so it was literally
how fast getting it is eminent
adamantium back who's gonna write the
story and when can we get it done and
then it was written it was drawn it was
done and it was out for sale and that
was it it was done extremely fast but
what this does is it basically sets
Wolverine going forward and facing off
against the x-men as the horsemen death
and it's actually pretty cool it's
actually pretty interesting to see that
happen because again it's its return to
familiarity its return to him going back
to the person that we know him being
going forward into the 2000s but what
having said guys we're gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rod quark if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]